and we'll just keep pumping for a bit
more
wow did you see that
good grief
that's about the height it's ever
gone wow
so did you manage to get that then
did you
did you see how high it went it went
very hard do you want to try it again
yeah go on then right yeah well the
symbol i want to talk about today is uh
is the symbol eta which uh is one of the
sim is a symbol we use for propulsion
efficiency this one here now this is
this is the original uh
jet engine so it takes in uh air
uh compresses it up in a multi-stage
compressor here to a high pressure then
you burn fuel in the air and it gets
very hot and when it gets hot it expands
so it's going a lot faster
and then it rushes out the back now now
this engine here is a is a modern uh a
modern turbofan engine as we call it and
this is the most modern engine the trent
800 that made by rolls royce and the way
this one works is um
air comes in at the front here and a
small amount of air really goes through
the compressor it's compressed to high
pressure then the fuel's burned here in
this section that's why it's all red
there's got the flames there that makes
the uh the air then expands goes faster
and it comes out of the back and on the
back of this engine
instead of instead of having a small
turbine we've got a very big turbo when
we take most of the energy out of the
air at this stage so it doesn't come out
very fast at the back it comes out quite
slowly and instead it's turned this
turbine and this turbine is turning
around and there's a shaft that runs
right through the middle of the engine
and that shaft turns this great big fan
on the front of the engine this big fan
pulls in a huge amount of a huge mass of
air but accelerates it to relatively low
velocities
so for a high propulsion efficiency what
you want is a lot of stuff going quite
slowly
in the old sort of jet engine we had a
small amount of stuff a small amount of
air going very fast that gave us a
similar thrust but it wasn't very
efficient because it takes a lot of
energy to make air go fast in a modern
turbo fan what we have is a lot more air
going through but it comes out slower
and that gives us greater proportion
efficiency now we can uh i can
demonstrate that with this water powered
with this water powered rocket so we've
got a foot pump we've got a guidance
system
and we've got some rocket fuel which is
just a uh which is just some water
so we'll just get outside onto the grass
and
it's not you have huge amounts of water
mostly it goes straight down so it's not
too bad
now actually the thing does go very high
and uh well the first thing we've got is
uh i need to put the
the launch site we have the the guide
rods so i'm going to put the guide rod
in the ground just here and this makes
sure that the rocket goes up
that's uh relatively straight and
doesn't fall over and come back and hit
you in the face
so we've then we've got the the rocket
it's just a it's just a coke bottle so
the first one in the first one we're
just going to we're just going to fill
it with uh
we're just going to fill it with air so
here's the rocket and
we're just going to
blow it up with air we're not going to
use any water at 35 pounds per square
inch the the nozzle uh comes out
the bond comes out and the air
compressed air inside here rushes out
the bottom and pushes the rocket into
the air
and because we've uh air is not very
heavy the air comes out the pressure in
here makes the air come out very fast
there's not very much air inside there
comes out very fast and makes the rocket
go
go up but because we've got a small
amount of air going very fast the
propulsion efficiency isn't very good
and it doesn't go very high
all right so we keep pumping and it's
going to go
any time now
oh
there we go
now that wasn't really very high
now when we go now what we're going to
do is we're going to put
um make it about a third full of water
and understanding the rocket up there'll
be water in the bottom and we'll pump it
up with air and then you'll see the air
bubbles coming up and it's got
compressed air on the top
and when the rocket goes off this time
it's pushing the water out now water's
much heavier than air
so the the air pressure can't make the
wear go water goes so fast so we've got
water coming out more slowly but water's
much heavier than air so effectively
what we've got this time is we've got
a large amount of stuff
coming out more slowly and this gives us
greater proportion efficiency so what
happens now is
for the same amount of energy we put in
to compress the air in the top we
actually get greater proportion
efficiency so we can actually go further
with this rocket so this rocket will go
very much further
wow
incredible when we put water in and
that's a bit counter-intuitive really
because people think oh it's got water
and it must be heavier so it won't go as
far but actually goes much further when
we've got water in because the
propulsion system is more efficient
oh and this time what we've done is
we've strapped the we've strapped this
camera on the side so we're going to
hopefully we have a nasa eye view
astronaut's eye view of the take off
what do you think's gonna happen i think
it probably won't lift off the ground at
all because this camera weighs more than
weighs more than the bottle
yes right okay let's try this one
right let's give it a go and see what
happens then
what oh god
it went off in that direction just
sprayed me with water and it actually
went further than i thought it was going
to go
i don't know if the camera's survived
though excellent well thank you for your
time
that's okay i'd like to see what happens
with that one then